A Kryptonian scientist, the "Days of Our
Lives" inspiration, and a young Barry
Allen. While these DC actors are no longer
with us, their performances will live on.
When it comes to daily newspaper editors who
unknowingly work alongside world-famous crime
fighters, J. Jonah Jameson of The Daily
Bugle tends to overshadow Perry White of
The Daily Planet. That's got nothing to do
with either of their journalistic abilities,
of course. J.J.'s just a larger-than-life
personality, and essentially one of the
villains in many Spider-Man stories. On the other
hand, Perry White's such a diehard print media
professional and advocate, he's been played by
many more actors than J.J., who's principally
associated with the version played by J.K.
Simmons in Sam Raimi's "Spider-Man" trilogy.
"He is, in my 40 years in this business,
the fastest typist I've ever seen."
Although he's not the only live-action Perry
White, the Superman world's answer to Simmons
is probably Jackie Cooper, who corrects
Clark Kent's spelling errors in "Superman",
"Superman II", "Superman III", and
"Superman IV: The Quest for Peace".
Despite a major role in one of the most
successful film franchises of the 1980s,
Cooper arguably never surpassed his
career zenith at the age of nine,
when he became the youngest actor ever nominated
for Best Actor at the 1931 Academy Awards.
But you could also argue that acting steadily in
film and TV from the early '30s up until 1990 is
a bigger accomplishment than any single role or
nomination. Cooper died in 2011 at the age of 88.
"Easy Miss, I've got you.
You've got me, who's got you?"
The tragically short nature of Christopher
Reeve's life has been widely publicized,
but when Margot Kidder passed away in May
2018 at 69, we still felt it was too soon.
Arguably, no major DC character has evolved and
improved over the decades more than Lois Lane.
Once a bumbling, air-headed klutz in constant
need of rescue, today's Lois is a world-famous
journalist and media personality, generally
depicted as a savvier operator than her Kryptonian
husband. Now and again, Lois does her own fair
share of meta-human adjacent crime fighting,
albeit in a far less conspicuous capacity
than her spouse or most of his colleagues.
Kidder appears in all the "Superman" films
co-starring Reeve, and we need only focus
on "Superman II" for examples of Kidder helping
undo the perception of Lois as a mere damsel in
distress. Kidder's Lois is not oblivious; she's
occasionally reckless, but only when journalistic
truth is at stake. Unlike previous iterations,
Kidder's Lois figures out that her bumbling
co-worker and the literal benevolent space god
that follows her around happen to be the same guy,
setting a precedent for future Lois Lanes who
don't buy that silly glasses disguise either.
The quartet of Batman films starting with
"Batman" and ending with "Batman and Robin"
can feel a little disjointed. Beginning in a
gloomy, quirky iteration of Gotham directed
by Tim Burton and ending with a candy-coated
cartoon fever dream imagined by Joel Schumacher,
the series foregoes a solid sense of
consistency ... except when it comes to Alfred.
"Well, I think I've embarrassed
him for long enough."
Veteran British actor Michael Gough holds down
the fort as Batman's congenial butler Alfred
Pennyworth in all four films, including "Batman
Returns" and "Batman Forever". As is more or less
customary for Alfred, Gough's version functions as
a voice of reason throughout Batman's adventures.
While he's more than happy to help Bruce and his
sidekicks save the world, he'd sleep a little
easier if his surrogate son could just get set
up with a nice girl and hang up the bat costume.
Gough's TV, film, and theater career started
in the mid-1940s, so to say there was a little
more to his career than his run as Alfred
would be a substantial understatement. Gough
passed on in March 2011 at 94, roughly
a mere six years short of triple digits.
With all due respect to Jeep Swenson, who
portrayed the venomed-up villain in "Batman
and Robin," it's probably fair to say audiences
prefer the version of Bane played by Tom Hardy
in "The Dark Knight Rises." But we don't say that
to diminish Swenson's acting abilities. After all,
the problems with "Batman and Robin"
extend far beyond its presentation of Bane.
Swenson caught more than one significant crummy
break during his essentially successful career,
in which he spent time in multiple sections
of the entertainment industry. His tenure
with the once prominent but currently defunct
World Championship Wrestling might have lasted
longer had that organization's creative
department come up with a less aggressively
offensive and anti-Semitic name for him
than "The Final Solution." Swenson died
shortly after the release of "Batman
and Robin" in 1997, at the age of 40.
You might not immediately recognize his name;
but we assure you, you know William Hootkins.
He's mentioned here specifically for his turn
as the corrupt Lt. Eckhardt in "Batman" and,
to a lesser extent, for the solemn
duty of performing in "Superman IV:
The Quest for Peace" in the guise of
Harry Howler. But the character actor
had a few more notable credits. For instance,
in "Star Wars", his character, named Porkins,
pilots a ship called an X-Wing and attacks a
moon-sized space station known as the Death Star.
Though known for minor roles in Hollywood,
his reputation in London's theater scene
was a different story. His obituary
cites his ongoing starring role in the
play "Hitchcock Blonde" as his career's
greatest triumph. But for actors with as
many projects under their belt as Hootkins,
what they're "known for" becomes a matter
of subjectivity in some respects.
He died in 2005 at the age of 57.
A fixture of televised comedy since her late '80s
stint on "Saturday Night Live," with subsequent
recurring roles on "The Simpsons" and "3rd Rock
From the Sun," Jan Hooks also appeared in "Batman
Returns". Evil businessman Max Shreck hires
her character to explain stuff to presumptive
Gotham City mayoral candidate The Penguin,
like why voters prefer fingers to flippers.
The Tim Burton-directed sequel
to "Batman" is not Hooks's only
DC-related credit. She also plays
a woman who claims to be raising
Superman's love child on CBS-TV's
"Superman 50th Anniversary Special",
a lighthearted slice of Superman ephemera.
Hooks passed away in 2014 at 57 years old.
Danny DeVito's Penguin recruits a wide variety of
minions for his crime spree in "Batman Returns,"
although they don't all have obvious utilitarian
value. If you're putting together a gang to
inflict the maximum amount of violence and mayhem,
then why bother signing up an organ grinder?
Penguin's thinking may be too sophisticated for
us to comprehend, so we just have to take it on
faith that the musical accompaniment produced by
Vincent Schiavelli's character, plus the amusement
provided by his dancing monkey, was essential
to Oswald Cobblepot's diabolical machinations.
Beyond the confines of "Batman Returns,"
Schiavelli carved out a niche as one of
the great character actors of his era with
turns in "One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest",
"Fast Times at Ridgemont High", and "Ghost".
"X-Files" fans may recognize him from the cult
favorite episode "Humbug," in which he guest
stars along with Michael J. Anderson and Jim
Rose, founder of the circus of the same name.
Schiavelli passed away in 2005 at the age of 57.
A high-ranking staff member at Arkham Asylum
who happens to be named "Dr. Burton" is not
even close to the goofiest thing in "Batman
Forever." But creating a toss-away character
for the purposes of delivering a good-natured
dig at director Tim Burton, who oversaw the
previous two Batman films, feels like a cheeky
move on the part of director Joel Schumacher.
We suppose it would be disappointing
for René Auberjonois if his only major
acting work consisted of a brief scene as a gag
character at the end of a lesser Batman movie,
but that's not even close to the case. Though he
contributed a physical or vocal performance to
an insane amount of TV shows, including numerous
DC and Marvel animated projects, Auberjonois is
most widely remembered as Odo on "Star Trek:
Deep Space Nine." He died in 2019 — not long
after the release of the critically beloved "First
Cow," one of his last movies — at the age of 79.
Sam Lane doesn't always get to live up to his
full potential in live-action Superman iterations,
so in a way, it's unfortunate that we
must gloss over Harve Presnell's role
as Lois Lane's estranged father on "Lois and
Clark" to discuss his more significant work.
The writer-director team of Joel and Ethan Coen
put themselves on Hollywood's radar with "Blood
Simple", but they didn't demonstrate their full
mastery of small town murder drama until "Fargo".
Used car salesman Jerry Lundegaard hires a pair
of hit men for an elaborate kidnapping scheme
designed to scam his father-in-law. The situation
collapses into a tragic, bloody shambles.
The American Film Institute once
ranked "Fargo" as one of the top
100 films of all time, and it would be
a completely different movie without
the veteran Presnell's conjuring
of Wade Gustafson — Lundegaard's
overbearing father-in-law and would-be mark.
Presnell died in 2009 at the age of 75.
Here's where we confess that calling
screen comedy legend Fred Willard a
"DC actor" is insanely reductive, and
the same statement applies to a handful
of entries on this list. Willard's oblivious
game show host-like persona has added to the
satirical irony of films such as "This Is
Spinal Tap", "Best In Show" and "Anchorman"
Willard also played the President of the
United States on Lois and Clark, as well as the
Deputy Mayor of Metropolis in the Superman 50th
Anniversary Special. Somehow, in Superman-related
media, Willard kept finding his way into
positions of political power. We'd chalk that
up to coincidence, if we believed in coincidence.
Willard passed away in May 2020 at the age of 86.
The single-season TV show "The Flash" from
the early '90s never managed to amass the
retro-cool credibility of "Batman" from
1966 or "Wonder Woman" from 1975. There
are probably multiple reasons for that,
but a glance at the show's intro music
and opening credits indicates that somebody
in charge wanted very much for The Flash of
network television to be the Batman of Tim
Burton films. CBS did not have the budget,
and Barry Allen didn't have the
angst to fulfill that expectation.
That's kind of unfortunate for Biff
Manard, as he appears in 17 out of
the 22-episode run of "The Flash." He was
still able to have a more-than-respectable
career and legacy outside his time as
Officer Michael Murphy though. Manard
shows up in both entries of the cult sci-fi
series "Trancers," and acted on a score of
television shows throughout the '80s and
'90s. He died in 2014 at the age of 71.
"Cyborg to Aquaman, where the
hell are you, fish stick?"
Cyborg has enjoyed something of a live action
revival as of late. As played by Ray Fisher,
he got a heck of a lot more screen time in
the recently-released "Zack Snyder's Justice
League" than he did in the original edit,
while an iteration played by Joivan Wade
has regularly appeared on Max's "Doom
Patrol" series. But back in the 2000s,
when studio executives falsely assumed television
could only handle one DC-based primetime drama at
a time, Lee Thompson Young was mass media's
one and only, flesh-and-blood Victor Stone.
Though he only drops by for three hour-long
adventures with Clark Kent on "Smallville,"
Young's version of Stone gets to be
a co-founder of the Justice League
alongside Green Arrow. That means the
onetime "Friday Night Lights" and "The
Famous Jett Jackson" star definitely set some
of the groundwork for Ray Fisher's tenure with
the character. Young, unfortunately, died
from suicide in 2013 at the age of 29.
Perhaps you already know that Rutger Hauer —
certainly one of the most recognized character
actors in sci-fi/fantasy — died in July
2019. And maybe you also already know he
played the nefarious Wayne Enterprises executive
credited only as "Earle" in "Batman Begins".
While we left Heath Ledger and Christopher
Reeve off this list because they're both
highly-publicized celebrity deaths, their
careers are both also closely associated
with their tenures as major DC characters. Hauer,
on the other hand, is probably too famous for the
relatively minor part he plays in "Batman Begins."
We happen to know it's possible to watch multiple
screenings of "Batman Begins," and still not
notice the classic "Blade Runner" antagonist
Roy Batty reassuring Bruce Wayne that he's got
the best interests of the Wayne legacy at heart.
Though Earle isn't a major part of "Batman
Begins," "The Dark Knight" wouldn't be the
same movie if Bruce Wayne had not overcome
a sleazy corporate ladder climber in the
first part of the trilogy. Ergo, we
can say there are two indispensable
sci-fi/fantasy/action franchises that
would not be the same today without Hauer.
"Bruce, you're supposed to be dead.”
“Sorry to disappoint."
Heath Ledger's once-in-a-generation performance
as the Joker tends to gobble up a huge chunk of
the discourse when it comes to "The
Dark Knight," and rightfully so. But
it's unfortunate how matters related to the
Joker overshadow so many other components of
Christopher Nolan's tour de force. Tom "Tiny"
Lister Jr. only spends a few moments onscreen,
but as the "tattooed inmate" who protects a
ship full of civilians by tossing the switch
to one of the Joker's bombs into the ocean,
he certainly makes those few moments count.
Lister's poignant appearance in "The
Dark Knight" isn't necessarily his most
impressive career accomplishment. Back
in the '80s, Lister went by the alias of
"Zeus" and main-evented the 1989 "SummerSlam"
pay-per-view card, teaming with "Macho Man"
Randy Savage against the tandem of Hulk
Hogan and Brutus "The Barber" Beefcake.
The rest of Lister's resume
includes featured roles in "Friday",
"The Fifth Element" and "Jackie Brown." Lister
passed away in December 2020 at the age of 62.
Logan Williams appears as young Barry Allen in
flashback and time travel sequences during the
first two seasons of CW's "The Flash." He
also had a recurring role on the Hallmark
Channel period drama "When Calls The
Heart," and landed his first role in
the Hallmark movie "The Color of Rain" at the
age of 10. He died in 2020 at 16 years old,
after a three-year battle with opioid
addiction. His mother Marlyse said at the time,
"His death is not going to be in vain. He's
going to help a lot of people down the road."
According to the Centers for Disease Control
and Prevention, nearly 69,000 people in the
U.S. died from overdosing on synthetic opioids
in 2020. Sadly, Logan Williams was one of those
statistics far too early into his life and what
should have been a long and promising career.
"Can't you remember anything?”
“I remember the Alamo."
[Laughter]
Though Paul Reubens' place in pop
culture history was assured by his
most beloved creation, Pee-wee Herman,
the actor-comedian also played a variety
of other roles, some of which trucked in
not-so-funny territory. Case in point:
"Batman Returns," which reunited Reubens with
"Pee-wee's Big Adventure" director Tim Burton.
He played Tucker Cobblepot, a Gotham City district
attorney who is horrified to discover that his
infant son, Oswald, is physically disfigured.
Cobblepot abandons his child, who is subsequently
raised by emperor penguins at the Old Gotham
City Zoo and later becomes the monstrous Penguin.
Reubens played a drug dealer in "Blow," the
restless ghost of a suicide victim in "Life
During Wartime," and the strange Mr. Vargas in
five episodes of "The Blacklist." He also played
Elijah Van Dahl, a more sympathetic version
of the Penguin's father, on three episodes
of "Gotham". He voiced several DC characters,
including Bat-Mite and the Riddler, on "Batman:
The Brave and the Bold" and the "Robot Chicken
DC Comics Specials", respectively. Reubens' death
from cancer at the age of 70 on July 30, 2023,
was mourned by fans and collaborators alike.
Though numerous actors have attempted to put
their stamp on the physicality of Batman,
one performer largely defined the Dark Knight's
voice for more than three decades. Voice actor
Kevin Conroy debuted as Batman in Bruce Timm
and Eric Radomski's Emmy-winning "Batman:
The Animated Series" in 1992 and continued
to voice the character in dozens and dozens
of projects, including other
DC Animated Universe series,
feature films and video games. Conroy
also played the Earth-99 variant of
Bruce Wayne on the CW's live-action Arrowverse
crossover event "Crisis on Infinite Earths."
Conroy, who studied acting at Juilliard,
began his career in the theater and amassed a
sizable number of live-action television credits,
including recurring roles on "Dynasty" and "Tour
of Duty." In addition to his many turns as Batman,
Conroy also lent his distinctive voice to such
animated series as "The Venture Bros.," "Ben 10:
Alien Force," and "He-Man and
the Masters of the Universe."
In 2022, Conroy penned "Finding Batman," which
detailed how his own troubled childhood and
experiences as a gay man informed his portrayal
of Batman, for "DC Pride 2022." Conroy died of
intestinal cancer at the age of 66 on November
10, 2022. His final performance as Batman will
be featured in Rocksteady Games' "Suicide
Squad: Kill the Justice League" in 2024.
Though created by Paul Dini and Bruce Timm, the DC
antihero Harley Quinn also owes a debt to actress
Arleen Sorkin for her iconic look, voice, and
attitude. Dini, who knew Sorkin from college,
saw a compilation reel of her appearances as
the eccentric Calliope Jones on "Days of Our
Lives," which included a scene in which she
was dressed as a jester. The scene inspired
Dini and Timm to create Harley Quinn, a
wise-cracking henchwoman and foil for the
Joker on "Batman: The Animated Series," and
they tapped Sorkin to voice the character.
She went on to play Quinn in five other
animated series and numerous video games.
"Fine! I'll show you! You'll be
sorry! I'll pull a big heist and
I'll be laughing at ya. Haha! You hear? Laughin'."
She logged more than 400 appearances
on the "Days of Our Lives", as well
as recurring and guest shots on series
like "Duet" and "Frasier." Additionally,
Sorkin wrote episodes of "Tiny Toon Adventures,"
created the short-lived sitcom "Fired Up," and
co-produced a 2010 documentary on Pakistani
Prime Minister Benazir Bhutto. Sorkin died
of complications from pneumonia and
multiple sclerosis on August 24, 2023.
From the mid-1960s until Tim Burton's 1989
film "Batman," Adam West was the on-screen
face and voice of Batman for a generation of
audiences. West played both the Caped Crusader
and his dashing alter ego, Bruce Wayne, on
ABC's "Batman" series from 1966 to 1968,
but was unable to parlay that show's
brief but meteoric fame into a more
substantial acting career. Like George Reeves
and many other actors who played superheroes,
West found Batman to be a blessing and a
curse: it elevated him to stardom but also
became a glass ceiling through which
he was unable to break for decades.
Perseverance and a willingness to spoof his screen
persona led to West's revival as a comic actor
and voice performer in the 1990s and 2000s. He
appeared, often as a smug version of himself,
in series like "King of Queens,” as well
as films like "Drop Dead Gorgeous," and he
voiced numerous characters in animated series,
including the deranged mayor on "Family Guy."
"Ugh, what don't you have in that belt?”
“Patience, for harlequin hoodlums like yourself."
He also reteamed with "Batman" co-star Burt
Ward to reprise their roles in animated form
for two features, including "Batman: Return of
the Caped Crusaders" in 2016. West's death from
leukemia at the age of 88 on June 9, 2017,
was commemorated by the city of Los Angeles,
which shone the Bat-Signal on
City Hall on June 15 of that year.
Season 1, Episode 6 of "Lucifer," titled "Favorite
Son," introduced viewers to Hank Cutter, president
of the Los Diablos motorcycle club, whom Lucifer
and Chloe suspect as the chief culprit behind
the theft of a shipping container belonging
to the Prince of Darkness from a warehouse.
Hank proves to be anything but the typical biker
captain. Though he looks tough as nails, what Hank
really wants to do is start his own clothing
line. He doesn't even like riding his bike.
Tom Sizemore was in the midst of a comeback
when he appeared as Hank Cutter on "Lucifer."
A substance abuse problem and other personal
issues had caused the Golden Globe and Screen
Actors Guild nominee to fall far from his
status as a popular character actor in
films like "Saving Private Ryan," "Heat,"
and "Natural Born Killers." After stints
in rehab and jail in the 2010s, Sizemore began
to rebuild his screen career, largely through
recurring roles on "Hawaii Five-0," "The Red
Road," and the 2017 revival of "Twin Peaks."
However, Sizemore was hospitalized
after experiencing a brain aneurysm
and stroke at his home in
Los Angeles on February 18,
2023. Doctors informed his family on February
27 that there was no chance of recovery,
and his family made an end-of-life decision for
the 61-year-old actor. He died on March 3, 2023.
Warner Bros.' 2010 feature version of DC's weird
Western title "Jonah Hex" was an unmitigated
disaster upon release. You can't place the blame
on its cast, however, including Lance Reddick. The
"John Wick" star plays a general store owner who
also supplies Hex with his heavy-duty weaponry.
A one-time music student who released an
album of contemporary jazz in 2010, Reddick
began acting in the late 1990s and earned his
first big break as Baltimore police lieutenant,
and later commissioner, Cedric Daniels on "The
Wire." The critical success of that series led
to steady work for Reddick in character roles,
often as authority figures, on series like "Lost,
"Bosch," and "Resident Evil," and in films like
the "John Wick" tetralogy — which cast him as
the Continental's concierge, as well as "White
House Down" and "Godzilla vs. Kong." Reddick died
of heart disease at the age of 60 at his home
in Los Angeles, California on March 17, 2023.
"I love you, son.”
“Stop!"
British actor Julian Sands played a crucial
figure in Superman's mythos in Seasons 9 and
10 of "Smallville." Sands played Jor-El, the
Kryptonian scientist who sends his son, Kal-El,
to Earth to avoid their planet's
destruction. He also transfers
his brainwaves into his son's spacecraft,
providing him with the superior intellect
to become Superman. "Smallville" was
not Sands' only foray into DC projects:
he also played Dr. Gerald Crane,
father of the Scarecrow, on "Gotham."
Sands rose to fame in the 1980s playing
diametrically opposite romantic characters:
Helena Bonham Carter's free-thinking love
interest in "A Room with a View" and a haunted
Percy Bysshe Shelley in "Gothic." He soon
proved adept at a wide array of characters,
from a malevolent spellcaster in "Warlock"
and a dashing entomologist in "Arachnophobia"
to a vicious pimp in "Leaving Las Vegas." No
part proved too offbeat for Sands: he was a
centipede in human form in David Cronenberg's
"Naked Lunch," the title character in Dario
Argento's "The Phantom of the Opera," and even
the voice of a cat in "Bobbleheads: The Movie."
Between these assignments were
numerous television roles, stage work,
and voiceovers for video games. An avid
hiker, Sands disappeared in California's
San Gabriel Mountains in January 2023. Human
remains found in the area on June 24, 2023,
were positively identified as the 65-year-old
actor, whose cause of death remains undetermined.